it said that symmetry is fundamentally
beautiful but how fundamental is that
hey crazies my life is pretty hectic in
March but it's Women's History Month so
I wanted to take some time to honor an
important woman in physics
I'm a neuter wasn't she a mathematician
technically yes but we got to borrow her
brilliance for a few days this story
takes place in gulten gin Germany in
1915 Einstein and Hilbert were trying to
finish general relativity but they ran
into a little snag if energy warped
space-time and space-time contains
energy then space-time should be able to
warp space-time that's what we call a
paradox they needed a fresh set of eyes
so they invited Newton to the University
by that time she was already known for
being a brilliant mathematician I mean
here's a list of her accomplishments but
the invitation was met with such heavy
resistance from the establishment that
Hilbert had to advertise her lectures
under his name enlist her as an
assistant totally ridiculous it's a good
thing they found a loophole though
because without news her general
relativity may never have been finished
writes relativity we were talking about
a paradox it turns out that not all
energy warps space-time just the stuff
in this stress energy tensor which is
all the energy except the energy in
space-time itself space-time is on one
side everything else is on the other
this was a good enough explanation for a
physicist but nuture was a mathematician
and like a true mathematician she
generalized it to death total energy is
what we call a conserved quantity which
is a quantity that does not change as a
result of her work on general relativity
new to new tably new to something such a
torque she noticed we're all conserved
quantities actually come from symmetry
now just to keep things clear we're not
talking about visual symmetry like
you've seen things like organisms or
playing cards we're talking about
mathematical symmetry to demonstrate
this I've made some expendable clones hi
what wait expendable well we can't
exactly do this in the space station
don't be ridiculous too many
distractions wah wah wah wah wah whoa
here's a clone just floating in space
he'll still be floating over here or
over here or over here if the clone is
moving in a straight line he'd still be
doing that here or here or here that's
what we call translational symmetry and
in all of those situations the clones
linear momentum is conserved the
symmetry implies that linear momentum
cannot change it's even true if we have
more than one clone in the system what's
happening doesn't change if they're here
or here or here yes we do lose the
symmetry if we put them over here but
then we also lose the momentum
conservation unless of course we expand
our system to include the Earth
rotational symmetry implies angular
momentum can't change if the system of
clones is here but oriented like this
instead then their physics doesn't
change which is true if they're like
this or like this or like this time
symmetry implies energy can't change but
that's a little harder to show with
clones the basic idea is that you don't
have to set zero time at the Big Bang
you can start your clock whenever you
want which is why we can have things
like time zones and we can switch our
clocks to daylight savings time although
no one ever should don't get me started
the main point here is that ma nutriment
was brilliant and her theorem was
incredibly insightful you might even say
it was beautiful and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy